Speaker 1: Luke Beasley here filling in for
David while he is away on paternity leave.
We've a fascinating story to talk about. So as
has been widely covered over the last few years,
Amazon's work environment is pretty horrible.
And there's been a lot of stories revealed
about people not being able to go to the restroom
properly, like they're driving down the road and
they have so little time that they're
expected to do something that they're
going to the restroom, you know,
in their car, in a bag or something
being expected to do way too much and not
being treated correctly for it. And one of
the reasons that this work environment was the
way that it was was actually sort of intentional.
Amazon, higher ups had designed it where you get
pushed so hard that there's no way you're going to
stay very long and they're okay with that. They're
going to have a really high turnover rate. But
then while you're there, extract as much work as
possible and not treat you the way that you should
be treated. So they go through a massive amount of
employees each month and each year who just go in,
they go out, they go in, they go out and they
grind them down so aggressively and so quickly.
So besides public pressure, it was actually
working for the higher ups. You know,
if you think from their perspective that we're
getting a lot of work out of these people and
making huge profits until now. And this is wild
reading from Yahoo! Finance. Amazon's no frills,
low wage, high turnover labor model is
beginning to show signs of stress. The
tech giant could run out of workers
to hire for its warehouses by 2024,
according to a leaked Amazon internal research
memo from May 2021, seen by the publication Recode
putting its service quality growth plans
and quick labor churn model in a pinch.
If we continue business as usual, Amazon will
deplete the available labor supply in the U.S.
network by 2024, the leaked report indicated. So
because they push their workers so hard, they're
literally going to be in a situation where at all
these given warehouses, there's all the vicinity
around where they can hire from, aren't going
to have enough employees, potential employees
who are within the type of employee that would
work that particular position who haven't already
left Amazon. Is that insane? So what is their
solution? Well, reading again from Yahoo! Finance,
the memo said Amazon had six levers it could
use to delay the labor crisis by a few years,
including raising wages and increasing automation.
But the only way to significantly alter this
timeline is to make sweeping changes to the
way it manages its employees. So obviously
automation could possibly help them with this,
take away some of the jobs that they need,
but is not going to do it all. And so I love how
they stumbled into what we've been all screaming
at them for a long time now. You were one of
the biggest corporations in the world. You make
tons of money. You can afford to pay your workers
correctly and treat them correctly. And it's crazy
because they are just now realizing, hey, if we
want people to work here, do we have to not abuse
them to be decent to them? Is that something
that we have to do? Yes. Unbelievable. Well,
I hope that they go in this direction, of course,
and treat all the workers the way that they
deserve to be treated. Wish they could have
figured this out earlier, but we'll take it now.